hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
today i am a ridiculously excited
to introduce you to the very famous mr
david eckles from eccles estate
david thank you so much for coming down
to my house yeah
i feel almost in all of you now i've
been watching you on youtube i've been
seeing you blowing up
so give a little instruction i'm sure
most people know who you are anyone that
doesn't
who is david echols i'm david iva's only
affection this year so
we got to the final we all get picked as
the winners i've done an
ff challenge and it's just blown up
since and when you said you did an ff
challenge you mean i moved to your house
yep in ireland spent a week with you
well we smashed it out the park so it
was brilliant
uh you came to ireland uh to try your
strategies
and it definitely worked you know i've
got
a lease option agreement and that's
actually in ireland by the way not
northern ireland oh that's that's in
ireland yeah
ireland itself at least option agreement
rent to rent
yeah we sold packets and sold deals and
we've got
an estate agent yeah you know um and we
joined ventured on the deal on the
seaside
which annoyingly we got gazumped
um but you've gone and replaced it
you've now got a land deal
um you've packaged and sold um deals
since then i mean what you've done in
the last few weeks
the last few weeks i two days ago i sold
the deal for two and a half thousand
pound
money in the bank money's in the bank
that's incredible because when you were
working in construction just to give it
a little back story yes i mean you were
working
previously before you were unemployed
for how long were you unemployed for
uh about two two and a half months okay
before that there what were you doing
i was a plant operator what does that
mean that means uh
basically like on road construction so
dumper driver
yeah long days sometimes very
unpredictable your work hours
sometimes 84 hours you know what i loved
you know what i loved as well in the
documentary when you were
when we were driving and you saw some
road construction workers and you were
like
what a [ __ ] job what's the matter with
you and you're like i used to do that
i'd never go back to that i'd rather be
unemployed oh it was horrible
you do work sunday's 12 hour shifts you
know 84 hours a week it's hard you know
i'm glad
you have to work to make money yeah and
wolf con what the property game
you still work with the money is you
know scalable it's much better
how much we getting paid when you were
digging roads sixteen pound an hour
six okay it's not bad it's not bad yet
but uh
you're putting in massive hours you
really have to work you've got no time
so okay sixty million i was on twitter
that's not fine yeah but then you were
also a contractor so you never know when
that work might stop and you've got a
break
there's this thing i was just i went to
home i hadn't got a day off all year
with the pandemic
yeah end of july i took my first week
off
i once went home this is that you
finished yeah so
everything just stopped had a stencil uh
that's what happens
you told me a couple months ago at your
house
that you couldn't make money in ireland
you were like ireland there's no jobs
there's no opportunities you can't make
money in ireland do you still believe
that
no you changed your mind changed my mind
you can make money enough
yeah that's the thing i always saw iron
right you have to go get a job
yeah stop many jobs there but you can
take your own action
property works i proved it you proved it
and inspired people too
so now i mean it's obvious listen i mean
here's the thing as well like at the end
of the financial freedom challenge we
spent a week together
you secured a rent to rent a lease
option agreement your packaging sold
some deals
you got a bunch of deals made a bunch of
money wonderful
but the financial freedom challenge it's
not about
actually making you financially free so
that you never have to work again at the
end of the week that's not the purpose
of it the purpose of it really
is to set you up so that you're set up
for life
financially you've got the skills so now
you know it's not like oh you're just
resting on your laurels you've got a lot
of work to do you know you've got to
pick up the pieces you've got to now and
some of the deals that we
um like annoyingly what happened with
that port rush deal
share the story because i was i was good
about that
this is the one this is the first time i
ever heard of it
we were the highest bidders yeah 165 165
that was fine everything was done the
profit and that was going to be a
hundred thousand pound from the house
yeah we're going to use the profits to
build the property at the back which is
going to make
at least another hundred thousand so
it's a two hundred thousand pound deal
uh we got a i got a call
it was after the ff challenge just after
we finished
yeah we finished on a sunday i got a
call on a tuesday to say
uh offers been accepted for 160 000
less and there was no they wouldn't let
us up or offer even though we were the
highest offer proof of funds did they
view it before us or something
i i don't know i remember saying to you
at the time and i was disappointed
because i was joint venturing with you
on that deal
but i remember saying to you at the time
listen rather than arguing with the
agent and focusing on it and be like oh
no it felt through
it's normal deal was full all the time
so i said just replace it just find
another deal
and now you've got this i've got a
better idea tell me about you tell me
about the
this one uh like that too i was looking
at properties
uh i just thought you know i'm sick
looking up properties today i'm gonna
look up land because it did uh the deep
dive
yeah it says i'm gonna put my knowledge
to that because you always say if you
don't use it you lose it so this is i'm
not going to lose it so it took out my
notepad from my notes
went through everything and about half a
mile up the road there was a site
for like six hundred thousand pounds
went in and walked out to gd fees
the average td fee coming in from the
agent is 1.7 million
and to build three properties is going
to be probably four or five hundred
thousand pounds
so what you going to do there's a couple
of if i'm going to try and jv
i'm going to either try and maybe get in
on the deal
some way that i can get a cut of the
profit yeah
but the thing is if you can find deals
that's the skill that you got from the
training and from the financial freedom
challenge
yes you made a bunch of money and you
got some deals but
you got the skills yeah to go and do
more and more and more so i'm really
really really excited my biggest fear
when i go to the financial freedom
challenge with people
is that when i leave their mindset
and their money thermostat you know if
you win the lottery you lose the money
again
yeah so that's it i'm not thinking if i
help them if i set them up for financial
freedom
is that kind of like them winning the
lottery and then when i leave
they're going to mess it up i think i
think the good thing about
our financial freedom challenge was the
affection
you know what we're capable of that you
wouldn't have picked us if you thought
we're going to drop
off yeah that definitely is true because
once you left you kind of get greedy
you think all right i made 10 grand this
week i want to keep
you know making money and you you sat
there one day evans did mention it on
his about the thermostat
that it did change i was happy with 16
pound an hour
now i've got two and a half thousand in
one day yeah
so it's scarable you know it changes the
way you think about money because that's
the thing i did my first financial
freedom challenge
um with with glenn and then
you know glenn did really well you know
they made lots and lots of money
and even six months after the challenge
he went on he made like 55 60 grand
but then he was using the money and he
was buying he bought a property from
auction without looking at it didn't get
a survey on it and he lost a load of
money on it
and oh and i said to him you know we had
a chat i mean glenn is still you know
still
close and friends today but i said to
him it's almost like
you've learned how to make money
but you haven't learned how to preserve
wealth
which means that it's just gonna be like
a bucket you can keep throwing water at
it but if the bucket's got holes in it
the the water's gonna come out glenn's
doing really well today
and um he's a top top guy but i think
when i went to your house and when i
went to evan's house and when i went to
lauren's house and helped them become
financially free
one of the things i was really conscious
of was also trying to change
their blueprint trying to change their
their thermostat and that's really hard
because when someone's been programmed
their whole life
to make a certain amount of money to
live a certain lifestyle
like and that's what when i was with
evans i said to evans you're moving
house you know and evan's moved into
into the nice apartment
um you know i mean what do you think
about that what do you think about the
whole thermostat thing
definitely true a lot of people are away
they think uh property need money it's
risky it's too good to be true
just get a good paid job so they're
happy with
10 12 euros an hour and when you come
and say oh yeah
you're going to do this you're going to
have your own house you're going to have
a business at the end of the week you
think
you're going to lose everything you're
going to be you know
it is true would you say it is true but
it's really programming
i i knew i could do it but i think older
people don't believe it
yeah and it's changing the thermostat
and they keep
i think as a society think well just
stay safe play it safe
and what you're talking about now is
you're talking about environment
yeah right and and one of the ways to
change your
money and listen anyone else anyone
that's listening to thinking what i know
if you're talking about
if you set a room for 21 degrees the
room is going to be 21 degrees
it might be a bit higher if there's lots
of people in the room it might drop a
bit if the windows open but it's going
to end up at 21 degrees
if your money blueprint is set to be
broke you could win the lottery you
could do a financial freedom challenge
with me
but you're going to lose it and you're
going to end up being broke because
that's where you're set
and that's what we're talking about how
to change that blueprint
and i think um one of the best ways to
change it is environment who you're
around
um you know jim rohn says that the
makeup of the five people that you spend
the most time with is going to be what
you're like
dan pena show me your friends i'll show
you your future so
one of the things that i've done with
you is
you've gone through the financial
freedom challenge but now you've also
got people around
you know success buddies samuel 365
the community evans law and the team
that you're now plugged into not to do
work for you
or to or to you know do anything for you
but just to be around you
so that when you've got people that
aren't believing in you and people from
from from back home or whatever they're
like well it sounds too good to be true
you've also got people that are pulling
you up i mean what's that what's the
support being like that you've had there
that's the big one believe it or not
one of the investors actually got for
the financial freedom it was on the 365.
so yes your network you always talk
about in firemen
i think you do succeed on the effects
and we had deadlines you know and i
think
everyone was there for success and it
definitely gets results the 365
it's life-changing yeah it's like 95
pound a month
but it's a small payment i've made two
and a half thousand in one day you've
got everyone there
answering each other's questions like if
you need a boulder and they're
contact this person they're all pulling
together yeah
and nobody gets jealous of people
they're all
want to see success and definitely
success beat breed success
absolutely an environment is stronger
than willpower definitely
you know you can try and psych yourself
up and motivate yourself but if you're
not around good people
pulling you up you're gonna really
really struggle okay top three things
you learned because i think education is
really important the financial freedom
challenge wasn't just about getting
results it was also about changing what
you know and who you are as a person and
helping you improve yourself
so what are the top three things that
you learned throughout the week three
things
it's training i wouldn't have done that
before training it's impossible because
yes you can watch youtube you can do
this but it's only so much
you need to do the training if you can't
invest in yourself
you don't trust yourself yeah training
is a small thing
being persistent you do get a lot of
knockbacks
you know knockbacks it happens even
today you do get
knockbacks but you have to keep fighting
through these here and i think the other
one is belief
yeah i do think you have if you don't
believe in your own ability well nobody
will
yeah and i think i had a little bit of
that but you believe in my ability
and you know you brought it out and i
believe in myself
and that's definitely that's how you get
results
so belief persistence training and
training definitely
so important and that's really solid
what about the time when
you were calling off agents from a book
and we had about two or three viewings
booked
and then you spoke to one agent in
person i think you saw an agent just get
coming outside of a property and i was
like oh there's an estate agent
go and ask her she's got any properties
and and you went and you sheepishly went
over and like excuse me um do you have
any
and i can't remember exactly what
happened but i think she saw that we
were filming
she didn't like the look of you she saw
me shoot but she's standing in the
background
loitering in the street where i'm from
england don't know the area and she she
basically
was a little bit um dismissive of you
and then just sort of said you know
no sorry you shouldn't be out here
asking me
that we were in lockdown why are you
filming and she kind of shut you down
and then you came over to me and i think
you thought that we were going to take a
nice break and
have a counselling session and whatever
but i was just like oh don't worry bring
that agent
and you were like oh you need to like
get over what just happened i think
um and then you were like we've actually
got a few viewings already booked i
think it's a full day
do you remember i was like no no it's
not a full day we've got like
two or three viewings like for the rest
of the day i think it's a full day
like talk to me about from your ex from
your point of perspective like what
happened
that's true because uh i did get a
knockback
i was like thinking oh what do i do what
do i say you just said forget about it
move on
and uh i thought three funes was a big
as a big day out basically because i
think we can do that in an hour and a
half
and a day he's got 24 hours in it come
on because uh that's
that was my you always say whoever
refused the most houses once i always
thought
we'll just pick three good houses but
we went there there's problems with
houses that don't look like they're on
the pitchers so
that's i think when you go and look at
like 10 12 houses
you can pick the best three you'll
package them
if you just go for three houses which
was the big day out
basically yeah it doesn't work and
that's why then if they're all crap
you've got no results
and also sometimes you might think a
house is going to be good but it's bad
or you might think a house isn't going
to be good and it's brilliant yes or you
might view a house that's not that great
but the agents got another one down the
road
you know and that happened to us land
you were convinced that your uncle was
going to give you a piece of land
you were going to build another house on
it because you're all going to be
wonderful
but that plan was pulled from beneath
your feet yeah what happened
uncle was really nice yeah we agreed to
have the land everything was set in
stone
but i think you came looked at it you
said
it's going to be a problem of the access
yeah and the sky you know the
perimeters basically basically just
getting planning on it
planning permission was the big the site
was nice
i always thought this is the perfect cue
but
that's where the training came in again
you know from you said it doesn't you're
not going to get it
yeah so that wrapped my plan that's your
main goal too you were devastated
yeah and also you went and checked out
with the council afterwards and
it turned out that i was i was right you
were right yeah this is it's impossible
uh
you definitely will not get planning
there and i should have done that but i
just thought this was nice
after that you were so convinced
in your fantasy world that you had to
buy a piece of land and build
your own home in ireland like
in your mind that was the plan yeah
and and and when you found that you
couldn't get planning on that land you
were like finding other pieces of land
what about this piece of land what about
that piece of land and you were so set
on
building your own house and i'm just
like dude you don't need to do that
you can just rent somewhere or you can
just like in the end we ended up doing a
lease option agreement on a house that
you can live in
but but but why are you still selling
there i think it's your own
personal touch you know you can buy
houses but i think if it's your own
own site you know do your own land it's
uh
it's your own touch when did the penny
drop that it was a bad idea
or at least a bad time definitely i
think the last
site we looked at uh it's in the middle
of a park
and a beautiful place it was cheaper to
buy a house next door than to build a
house
yeah because the land was like 55 000
and it's gonna cost you probably 85
grand to build it yeah
and you could buy a brand new one for
120 yeah
to build it and yeah a certificate
through the whole problems raising
finance
certain mortgages it was just easier to
get a buy let and not only that but also
if you bought your own house to live in
you could put down a small deposit yeah
if you have to build it you have to get
development finance which is expensive
yes
it just didn't make sense and i said to
you i'm like dude it's the kind of thing
that you can do
when you're financially free you've got
a successful business and i said you
rather than focusing on trying to build
your own house
you need to focus on building something
else that's that's when the peony
dropped well
he says why don't you put the money into
the business yeah build your business
and then use the profits from your
business to put into your own house
exactly that's when a drop realize that
if i use all my money i think that's
what a lot of people do they seem to
build their own house
lovely house but they've got no money
but thank you
you said it was like a plant in a tree
one time if you really nurture it
it's going to produce apples and it's
like building your business if i
nurture it do well it's going to keep
reducing the profits yeah
and that's when the penny dropped then i
thought
you know it's just the bubble busting
yeah but it's also
it's a better plan because if you put
everything into building a house you
might own your own house that you've
built but you broke
yeah and that's what a lot of people
around your area are like that's what
they do i think
they've got a mindset of i don't want a
mortgage so they'll go to like australia
whatever england
save up all their money build a house
they're set up
but then they're back working at jobs
that they don't like so
it's a bit back to front but it's
definitely
it's the best way for however we then
secured a lease option agreement
yeah on a property so now you have got a
home
i do yeah in ireland there's a tenant in
there at the moment
yeah but but what do you do now living
wise because i know at the moment you
seem to be back and forth a little bit
like what are you where what's going on
back home uh i i've got an option though
i thought i wanted to be home
to get home i needed to do this you've
done that and more
now you've got an option like well i can
scale the business here in the uk
i can do business in ireland and that's
what i'm at now so you're kind of just
doing a
bit of an on a bit of the uk i can do
whatever i want no i'm actually going
home this weekend for three weeks
and uh how are you in ireland ireland
yeah and it's all choice
i've got i've gotten faster looking for
deals there i've
it's basically changed now so it's so
interesting because you were so set
before on
like i need to move home but to do that
i need to get a piece of land where i
can build
i'll live in a static caravan you have
this idea
and actually i think as a and as well a
lot of people don't like the idea of
debt
they don't understand the concept of
cash flow no they just think of money in
the bank rather than
money dripping in you've got your rent
to rent and stuff like that which is
dripping money in yeah you've got your
deal sourcing which is quick cash
you're happy to get into debt as long as
it's good debt and i said to you i said
dude if you get into debt
to buy a piece of land to build a house
on it that's bad debt
yeah whereas if you could because how
are you going to pay it back
and people think i'm an advocate for
debt i'm not
i'm an advocate for good smart business
sophisticated business
so we really change with some life goals
a bit yeah that's i will pick up on that
because people you mentioned debt they
think oh this is terrible or
credit cards or anything they don't
understand they just think debts debt
good debt is you say buy something
that's generating the cash flow
that can pay for something else yeah bad
debt you told me about the house that
i couldn't rent the house because it was
mine and i would have to keep paying a
mortgage
yeah that will be good yet if i could
get have a business scalable
that's going to pay for that mortgage so
it's technically a free house
i got a lot of people asking about why
that whole bit so people don't
understand the context of it because in
the documentary there was one point
where you said i've got two words for
you joe
f you like what was going on there and
give me some context to that i
started last february the 2020 just
before the lockdown
uh this was the crash course i think it
was the crash course
the last crash course before lockdown i
think it may have been yeah so one off
but you were there
okay i'll go to bristol uh see what
samuel's about so i went there
and like that too had this little voice
in my head saying oh
do go for trip i actually had everything
ready to go to do the dsm and uh
this thing i'm gonna do it and it's just
money that i need
and it's like i don't know if i can't
afford it now and then
joel i said come in and they're saying
don't do the training don't do this
and then i thought i held back yeah so
that that really that was the worst
thing actually the best thing in the
worst thing that happened to me because
i didn't do the training that day
yeah i didn't sign up did so you were
kind of just
let me get this right because this is
terrible so you were
on the verge february 2020
of going all into property i was still
selling yes going all in
how did there i had it you were about to
register for some training
yeah and you were about not just forget
training you were about to go
all in right forget the training
more a case of you're about to go all in
on property
joe lysett a comedian came into the
crash course
and told you not to do the training
caused a big scene
and that made you have a little voice
thinking maybe i shouldn't you
backed off yeah it took you a almost a
year later
before you actually thought now you know
what i'm going to go for the eviction
and you and and it basically slowed you
down on your journey for a year yeah
so that was why you said f you joe
uh basically he did stop me that day
and two things i would have been a lot
further on on property
but on the flip side of it you know uh
admit me rethink
to say but you know what what you're
talking a lot of people out there is
talking
skeptical and yeah i went all in i know
it changed i've done the effects and
i've done a ff challenge i've made
that money i made that day you know what
i've made there on monday
that two and a half thousand i could
never make that in one day unless
you won a prize basically it's so uh
julie said you know it did put me off
and now when i look back that how much
he slowed me up i was really
basically pissed off he ought to be
ashamed of himself
because if he if joe likes it put you
off how many other people did he put off
exactly
how many other people did he potentially
did he pull their dreams like when i
pulled someone's dream from them
like when i pulled your dream of buying
your own house today the reason i pulled
that dream from you is because
it didn't work yeah it was a dream but
it was backed with
it wasn't backed with facts and evidence
that would actually work it wasn't
practical so i'm like dude that's not
going to work
no i'm actually saving you what joe
lycee did
was he pulled a dream from you which was
actually something that does work
which is being a deal sorcerer which
every single week i went on winners on a
wednesday people come on and share about
how they're making money in property
being a property investor a property
entrepreneur he was like no no
you're too poor to do that you're
vulnerable
you can't and he pulled that from you
and actually stopped you for a year and
stopped many other people potentially
forever
he did stop i had the form ready to sign
it and
i listened to him i thought maybe he's
right and i stopped i went home
i'm still full of energy like i'm
looking at problem and then that just
died off yeah
a little yeah i thought all right maybe
properly is too good to be through
and i gave up on it and then i just came
back i said you know what
it's not because i kept watching
warner's on a wednesday i'm thinking
that could be me
and i started reaching out to people and
i realized their story was so genuine
and thought
i'm going to give this a go i applied
and i got on the affection
and just blowing up so i i i was to fly
home
that friday morning yeah and i got a
call on the thursday night to say
do you want to be part of the fiction
and i did yeah took the accent and now
and you actually didn't you didn't have
to pay for the addiction no
i mean you had to pay for hotels and
stuff and you had to pay a petrol and
you know but you didn't even end up
paying for the training that you
that you did i i've been so thankful
that has
changed my life i've got everything out
of it and more you know and maybe
it worked out a good thing because maybe
i wouldn't have got this opportunity
you know that i really did come back
yeah
so what would your message be to someone
watching this that's maybe where you
were a year ago
you know they're thinking i want to be a
property investor i want to be a
property entrepreneur haven't really got
much money
i don't really know i mean i mean what
would your advice be in terms of mindset
and your practical advice and how to
help them out well
if you don't do it now you'll never do
it you can go back to your job and
complain and say i should have done this
[ __ ] is on that but if you invest in
yourself
you do the training it's like 995 for
dsm you can go deal source
you don't have to register your business
you can code source and you're going to
make that back
in the first deal and it's scalable like
you can make
used when you started the very first day
on the infection you had up a board
saying like this person's making 10
grand a month and i thought that's
that's a lot of money and now since i
sold the deal on monday for two and a
half hours like just one day in the
month
yeah 10 grand is not a lot i know and
that was that deal
useful wasn't to do me i was i was i
only found out about it doesn't happen
yeah i said what you've been up to since
the
there's the challenge yeah another thing
as well is really interesting
i was on the plane on the way back to uh
england
after the financial freedom challenge my
wife was heavily pregnant
right so so i literally got back and
pretty much straight away
she had the baby um so timing-wise
it was a close call because i almost
couldn't come to ireland and almost put
it back more but i thought you know what
joe lysa has already delayed you enough
yeah
you know we cannot delay this anymore so
i came out when she was nine months
pregnant
we did what we did um what in just a few
words what was the week like itself
oh that was a brilliant it was hard you
know but
really reality this is what you have to
do is get on there
look go to the properties all the people
would sit look at a laptop all day
there's no houses you always say get out
there talk to agents
yeah what have you got you know they've
got deals we've got to rent to rent
how do we film this so we went to
belfast we locked port rush
dairy with phone deals you can do your
own ff challenge you
you don't need you to do it and this is
the thing everyone's like
can you come to my house to do an ff
looking back
you don't need you if you have the
training just do it
just get out you don't need everyone
thinks i need samuel can you come to my
house
but everything's there if you've done
the training just
implement it i love that point it's like
people think i've got a magic wand
i'm going to wade over them no all i'm
going to do is i'm going to come around
the house
i'm going to share with them the skills
and strategies kick them up the bum
yeah and assist them but but as you said
you can come on the crash course yeah
the crash course is a free training
program it's free
like you know you don't have i don't
have to physically come to your house
i'm putting the training on for
everybody it's open for all
and um samuel 365 95 pound a month
and the first week it's free too so
people don't even
join up go on network get out there
ninety five point a month they make
that's 95 per month but
you're gonna make that money tenfold
yeah and for that you get unlimited
mentoring
unlimited coaching and support and i
don't know if you know this but
that's how i actually get on the fixing
go on
because i had it was my first ever call
and i was like
i think it was a tony crook and it was
like two o'clock and then i was back to
that again
kind of making up excuses um a bit too
busy today
and i said you know i'll just do the
call so it's on the call
tony really gave me good guidance on a
rent to rent what
what we should structure it and i said
did you apply
for the affection i said it did didn't
get picked
and i got talking to him and he gave me
a call back that evening saying that
somebody
dropped out and expect that again people
say oh if i got the chance of a ticket
people got the chance yeah and still
didn't do it
yeah excuses i know they're probably at
the work today thinking
oh i should have done the training so
that all came from the 365 call
that's amazing it was the best 95 pound
yeah i ever spent yeah yeah it's on
limited calls you've got
your daily routines you've got calls to
you you've got calls
alistair tony david taylor everybody so
it's
i can't recommend that enough you know
at the end of the week i told you you
need to start building your own business
you set up now your own business set up
your own estate agent
what's it called echoes of sits echoes
of states there's such a good ring to it
so what's the plan with echoes of states
now what's the plan with the business
now what i'm going to do
is uh set up that in northern ireland
because it's uk it's easier for me to
keep it uk the uk
uh the property market there is booming
at the moment so i'm gonna
get properties onto that start selling
it and
maybe if i do deal source it's gonna be
not like a conflict of interest i'm
gonna keep that a bit separate
if i sell a deal at an investor once
they finish the refurb i can put that
deal on through my estate agent so that
keeps me
whenever i do move home i've got a
scalable business there now working for
myself
and you you advise me to do that so yeah
i think it makes sense
because when we were out and about in in
in northern ireland we were saying the
estate agents some of them aren't that
great you know
and you were like you do a better job
with this exactly so i think that's
really good build a business
it works goes alongside deal sourcing
yeah um someone wants to get in touch
with you whether it be for
um if they want to buy a deal off you or
if they just want to send you a message
of congratulations or whatever it might
be
how's the best way to connect i've
basically i've got a lot of people
reaching out you know they call me they
get through facebook
instagram every single person i message
or message me i
get back to everyone yeah you know you
always say
don't keep it to yourself yeah you help
me
and if i can help somebody else i will
do that so if they reach out i will get
back
and uh that's what i want to do now is
how do we reach out facebook instagram
what's your instagram
uh david underscore echoes 90.
great david underscore eccles 19. is
that you that birth 90
yeah great love that and also as well
your online presence has been blowing up
in fact when you were in ireland
people were recognizing you i actually
got a i couldn't believe it
uh just to realize how big it was i rang
an estate agent i've never done belfast
before so
he's like are we on the affection and i
was like
oh who is this you're david eckles
because you you said to say i'm off the
business partner and it's like
samuel leeds is that samuel leeds and
then we actually
turned up to that agent crazy so a lot
of people
it's a small world property is a small
world and it's a lot smaller than what
you think
yeah you think nobody knows but people
do know who you are and
it's a really really good market yeah
you know i think
i loved it and it proved it now to a lot
of people that northern ireland
is brilliant and you're getting a lot of
business from social media
massive either still you just sold was
on instagram
believe it or not two of my days of soul
was on instagram i've got people
asking to joint venture yeah i i've
you know it's never too much to take in
i've got deals coming on my way codeine
sorcerers
yeah at scaling so it's really too much
to take in it has that has to become the
new normal your thermostat's now
changing i know it's turned up
yeah and it's out of state now that i'm
thinking okay this is getting so big
that
do i have to employ somebody that's the
stage it's got to know within a few
weeks
that's incredible yeah and i'm thinking
from being
unemployed to do i have to employ
somebody that's how quick it's going
yeah yeah when you reckon you'll employ
somebody
uh well my partner is uh into admin
so really that's really helping me on
the websites
yeah that end the thing is she's looking
to is she looking to leave her job soon
yep when do you reckon she'll leave her
job uh i would say
in the next few months wow brilliant
every yeah because everything is taken
off that quick that
it's it's still fresh this is like weeks
we're only weeks
yeah i know i saw the rent around two so
it
does work it's all the strategies not
your rent right now
in ireland no short a different range
event i says i'm gonna ring uh
some people reached out to me i says
right i'm gonna go to liverpool to meet
them
yeah and i said right to make it worth
me why they wanna
do something when i'm there so i was
literally first ever call
to liverpool and i rang about a rent to
rent i secured it over the phone
and i desourced it to them wow
hang on a minute someone says can you
can you meet me in liverpool
you agree to me and then before you go
you ring up some agents in the area you
secure a rent to rent
yeah and then when you get to liverpool
you meet that you have your meeting yeah
and then you go and view the agent and
then you sell the
rent to rent to the people that you're
meeting yeah
what where i got that idea from
you said you spoke in belfast once yeah
yeah
he told me i says all right and then he
says well i says you said you didn't get
paid for it correct
and you said you went and you sold the
deal to make it worth your while so yeah
i was tending to be there
samuel that's exactly right i had a
speaking engagement in belfast
i said i'll come and speak at your event
this is some years ago i said i'll speak
how much you're going to pay me
and they said we can't pay you we've got
no budget it was actually um zucchini's
pin meeting
yeah i said no problem they said well
pay your flights and expenses
and stuff i thought well i can't come
for free
but what i'll do is i'll go and while
i'm on route
i'll make books and viewings and i did
exactly that so it's so good to see you
doing the same thing
yeah i was trying to implement what you
said so i found the rent to rent
i went it was literally perfect and
i was trying to underestimate it about
400 pound a month's profit and it's
looking like it's gonna get 700 pounds
great 750 profit nice
everything was fully furnished do you
wish you kept it for yourself
yes and no uh i could help other people
you know that they're local
it gets them can on the property that's
from liverpool
you've got a meeting in liverpool with
some liverpool ladies
you find a deal in their hometown while
you're on route
and then when you get there you sell it
to them dude
that's impressive yeah that's impressive
like you could say i'm on the property
ladder to know what pays
this is that profit is going to pay
their rent yeah and it's
extra so they're happy i'm happy what
about when you got inside your rent to
rent and you were like i want to live
here
i know i know i thought this was uh
cheap you know it was
like 650 a month and i thought if i
could get money from
renting the rooms out yeah i'm like dude
you don't want to live in a friggin
you know now that's on you listed down
airbnb um yeah and
how's that going that's good that's
fully booked up into august the 10th
brilliant yeah hey dude you're freaking
killing it i'm so glad you came onto the
show
guys i'm sure you can appreciate how
well he's done
how far he's come such a short space of
time this is
um you know this is winners on a
wednesday but i'm going to get him back
on the channel probably six 12 months
and we'll see how he's doing
wanted a bit more time to really grow
his business and his and his adventures
um hey show some support for david smash
the like button
also if you haven't seen his documentary
yet check it
out check it out you can watch the full
um part 1 and part 2 series right up
here
check it out watch the playlist it's
incredible don't forget to subscribe as
well you can do that right here
and also join me at the crash course
where you can learn to do the exact same
thing too on the house i'll see you
there god bless